100 milliards de dollars pour 2020
c'était déjà une promesse qui n'a pas
été tenue
ce doit être maintenant une obligation
c'est absolument indispensable pour
qu'il y ait un accord sur les 100
milliards il n'y aura pas d'accord à
paris alexandra le président français
tient vraiment beaucoup à ce que ce soit
un succès mais là en ce moment où est-ce
qu'on en est est d'abord le président
français veut éviter à tout prix l'échec
de la conférence sur le climat à
copenhague en 2009 vous vous souvenez
mais pays se sont séparés sans accord
alors cette fois ci il veut que les pays
s'engagent clairement avec des objectifs
clairs de réduction des gaz à effet de
serre avant que la conférence démarre en
amont de la conférence et il ya déjà
cinquante six pays qui l'ont fait parmi
les plus grands pollueurs de la terre
les états unis par exemple se sont
engagés à réduire de 26 entre 26 et 28 %
d'ici à 2030 la russie entre 25 et 30%
d'ici 2030
l'union européenne 40% et le canada
seulement 30% alors voilà l'engagement
des pays et même la chine a décidé de ça
c'était d'un accord de dernière minute
au mois de juillet de réduire à partir
de 2030 ces émanations de gaz à effet de
serre donc 56 pays la grande question
c'est est-ce qu'ils vont faire et est
suffisant ce à quoi il s'engage à ce que
c'est suffisant déjà les chiffres
parlent par eux-mêmes 56 pays sur 195
c'est évidemment pas suffisant et aussi
si vous regardez la dernière colonne
céline on voit que la russie et l'union
européenne qui sont engagés à réduire de
30 ou 40% par rapport à 1990 mais le
canada et les états les états unis
seulement par rapport à 2005 donc c'est
évidemment c'est beaucoup moins par
rapport à eux
les réductions globales et finalement
j'ai parlé d'ailleurs sur ce sujet à
corinne lepage l'ancienne ministre de
l'environnement française qui m'a dit
que au rythme où vont les choses ça
n'ira pas jusqu'à l'objectif de moins de
2 degrés celsius que s'est fixée la
conférence et finalement c'est l'argent
qui est le nerf de la guerre comme
toujours le président hollande l'a dit
tout à l'heure
100 milliards de dollars par année
seront nécessaires pour aider les pays
en développement à faire leur transition
énergétique
on est encore loin du compte on n'a que
10 milliards d'engagements pour le
moment dans les coffres il reste trois
mois
alors on espère encore et ça marche
merci alexandre au plaisir